Jenna Rowland's is the most feminine
person I've ever known
she's also the toughest suppose if you
were building an actress that was Bionic
or something she'd be it beautiful
intelligent aggressive nurturing erudite
brave well-read tireless confident warm
cold unflinching glorious everything
yeah that's about right Jenna Rowland's
is everything and tonight she is
receiving an Academy Award first Oscar
in the family all I can say is about
damn time
I myself come from a filmmaking family
my parents made movies out of the house
mom was a working actress long before I
was born but when she worked with John
he was different they made different
types of movies Jenna started them dad
directed them there were a team
she was his creative partner he was hers
and they made movies not because they
wanted to be rich or famous or I don't
even think they cared if they were good
or not they made them because they were
interested in them only they shot him at
home
strange crew members dominated the house
all the time eating sometimes sleeping
there my bedroom was the Edit room it's
made for an interesting childhood it was
a great time it was an exciting time and
they did some fantastic work watershed
kind of film sent I think it was at that
time my rides here I think it was at
that time
that Jenna turned into a supernova may
belong getting Gloria Swenson many more
Sarah Lawrence
Myrtle Gordon I mean you look around
there's a lot of great actresses in this
room but she's the best one on the
planet
of course I'm her son as a kid you'd
always know when Jenna get apart because
she would lock herself in her room for
three months and wouldn't come out
people bring her food you check in on
her once in a while because maybe you
had something to talk to her about but
she never left the room and when you
came in you'd say hi mom and she put her
script down politely and say hello and
you knew that even she you knew that she
loved you
but you also knew what you really wanted
to do is get back to her work so there'd
be an uncomfortable pause and you'd
leave the room and out of the corner of
your eye you'd see her picking her skirt
back up again and that's the thing with
Jenna her level of interest the work she
puts in it's like a crazy person when I
was 8 years old my mother after school
read the Encyclopedia Britannica to me
from A to Z and explained everything as
she went because she thought it was fun
remember that made a movie about that
one yeah so when you have the pleasure
to see a Jenna Rowland's performance and
we've seen them all and it was really
great to see all that stuff just know
that it's a work of manically devoted
crazy person a wild pack animal so
insanely interested in her work that
she's run through every emotional
physical spiritual cerebral life choice
for that character thousands of times
and that's why when you come to the set
she sits there and she says ready to
shoot bring it on
a number of years ago I made a movie
with her called The Notebook and thank
you very much we had a scene to shoot it
was about a woman who had Alzheimer's
and you know towards the end of the film
she she can't remember her husband or
anything else and she she remembers her
husband for five minutes and she and
Jimmy Gardner get to have a moment
together before she goes away and we
shot a we should had a very nice lovely
subtle scene and Jenna's performance was
nuanced than just lovely and
unfortunately I hadn't done enough
homework so when I I saw the film put
together what the film really needed was
and their kind of a very sudden release
moment like oh my god I've seen you and
and I just needed it and not only that I
I was the one that had to go on and tell
her that we needed to reshoot she looked
at me and she said so what you want me
just remember and just burst into tears
at the drop of a hat and and I said yeah
that that's uh that's kind of what we
what I what I need and can you do it and
she looked at me and she said son I can
do anything
and she could ask Jenna Rowland's 60
years of acting over a hundred recorded
performances a lifetime of achievement
lastly I can graduated congratulate all
the actors in the room acting it
sometimes can be very difficult and at
other times it can be quite simple
so in an opening night the great
Myrtle Gordon a legendary stage actress
is is struggling to find her character
and he just kid find it and she's
talking to her director and she says
she's nothing she's nothing does she
wind or does she lose that's all I need
to know does she wonder does she lose
I'm beginning to think I'm crazy for
even asking the question anymore does
she win or does she lose well mom come
on up tonight you win